[Music]  uh  [Music]  is  [Music]  welcome to the vicious  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  hello  everybody here for the interview  me too  what do you drive  i got the jet bike they're ready to see  you mr crew oh good great  [Music]  here we go  distinguished villains  my name is crow  i feel like i'm talking too loud even  though our proximity doesn't require  this kind of volume  you seriously think a puny little child  can be a villain  yes i am pretty despicable you don't  want to cross me  come back when you've got something evil  to impress me  [Music]  i'll distract them  this is the biggest day of my life  this kid just stole something from the  world's villains in the world  time to strike now i will be a super  villain  now all i need is otto where is ato  are you pulling on my legs right now  otto where's the stone oh  [Music]  did you just trade my future  for a petra  oh i didn't mean to scare you now where  is groom  [Music]  you